today on the matt wells show democrats
have made it clear that they absolutely
will pack the court if they're given the
power to do so overturning a
a century of precedent and setting us
down a very dangerous path
their defense of this plan is to as
always redefine the term court packing
claiming that republicans are packing
the court simply by filling vacant seats
all of that is crazy we'll talk about it
also five headlines including
an unlicensed security guard apparently
hired by an nbc affiliate
then proceeded to shoot and kill a trump
supporter and tucker carlson talks about
ufos and brings up a number of important
questions there
uh so we'll we'll discuss that as well
and in our daily cancellation as is my
custom
on this glorious columbus day i will
cancel those who have been trying for
years to posthumously cancel the great
explorer all of that on the way but
first look
i don't know about you but i've got a
list a mile long
of books i want to read the problem is
finding the time to actually read them
there's a lot of knowledge just sort of
sitting out there to be consumed but not
nearly enough time to consume it all and
that's why
i love and recommend thinker.org
thinker.org
they summarize the key ideas from new
and noteworthy nonfiction giving you
access to an entire library of great
sized books
in bite-sized form of great books i
should say bite size form the idea here
is to is to is to
get the knowledge the insight even if
you don't have the time to read the
whole book
it's the closest thing to the matrix
where you can plug in and learn karate
in 12 seconds or whatever
i mean it's not that but it's as good as
we'll get in our reality to that you can
read or listen to hundreds of titles in
a matter of minutes
from old classics to recent bestsellers
they've even got a book
from some guy named matt walsh not sure
i recommend that one but
they have many great books and great
minds in their catalog
thinker.org offers a large variety of
titles across many categories from
current affairs politics business
education history relationships
personally i gravitate to the history
books but i've dabbled in some of the
other categories and found it very
fruitful as well on thinkor.org
if you want to challenge your
preconceptions expand your horizons
become a better thinker
go to thinkord.org t-h-i-n-k-r-dot-org
to start a free trial and download the
app today let them know you heard about
them
on the matt wall show as well that's
thinker.org
all right well you know one of the
primary tools of the left one of their
most effective tools a tool that has
helped them
win the culture and crush their
ideological foes
is that of redefinition we talk about
this a lot on this show probably so much
that you get tired of hearing about it
but
definitions are important we can't
communicate without them
to communicate what does communication
mean to communicate is to convey
meaning if you control the definition of
words then you control communication
you make it so that people are
submitting to your worldview
advancing it promoting it agreeing with
it implicitly simply by speaking
even if they don't want to agree with it
they still are perfect example off cited
on this program is the word gender
the left took the word gender which was
always a grammatical term
words had a gender not people that's the
way it used to be
and they invented a new use a new
definition of that term and for decades
since then even people who disagree with
their gender theories
still use the word gender in the context
and way that the left wants
thereby agreeing with their underlying
premise that humans have
both sex and gender which are distinct
many other examples could be mentioned
here but
the fascinating thing is to see this
process play out in real time which we
do quite a lot now
with the advent of the internet and
24-hour cable news
it can happen instantaneously you could
wake up in the morning and have
breakfast under the security and comfort
of knowing that a certain word means a
certain thing
and by lunchtime when you're eating your
sandwich that word means something else
entirely it's that fast
just like that the word changes meaning
so the latest example
not quite as far-reaching or culturally
significant as the word gender but still
impactful in its own way
is the term court packing now
as long as this term has existed which
isn't for very long the grand scheme
but it has been in reference to any
scheme
to add more justices to the supreme
court add more seats
not merely fill a vacancy add more in
order to seize ideological control of
the
of the supreme court that's what the
term meant but now the democrats
clearly plan to do this themselves and
given the terms negative connotation
they've decided to
all at once redefine it and just like
that
court packing is not adding seats to the
bench but simply
filling empty seats many prominent
voices on the left have adopted this
talking point
as i said all at once just overnight
including dan rather who tweeted
can we at least recognize that court
packing at all levels of judiciary
has been the republican playbook for
decades asking for merrick garland
no dan we can't recognize that because
it's a fantasy it's false
but it's a fantasy that democrats are
widely engaging in here's a senator dick
durbin
on nbc listen senator durbin did the
fact
that vice president biden used the
phrase court packing
was that a tell of where the vice
president stands on this that
that he doesn't want to see this happen
well i can tell you that
we're getting this question it's a
common question being asked because
american people have watched the
republicans pack in the court over the
last three and a half years and they
brag about it
they've taken every vacancy and filled
it did you know that they've sent
us and we have approved only with their
votes i might add
uh 10 people who have been judged
unanimously
unqualified by the american bar
association do you know how many
judicial nominees came from obama who
were judged
unanimously unqualified none they've
taken every vacancy and filled it he
says as opposed to what dick
leaving the vacancy open in the name of
of what good sportsmanship
this really is the democratic argument
it's not a straw man they are arguing
that republicans should leave judicial
seats open
not just the supreme court but judicial
seats in general should be left open
in order to be nice to the democrats
that's their argument here's a senator
chris coons making the same argument
well i'm going to be laying out the ways
in which judge barrett's views
um her views on reaching back and
reconsidering an overturning
long-settled precedent
are not just extreme they're
disqualifying she has taught at a
well-regarded law school
she clerked for justice scalia but she
has views that make her not qualified to
serve on the supreme court
president trump has said he would only
nominate someone
who would overturn the affordable care
act taking away health care protections
for more than 100 million americans in
the middle of a pandemic
and both president trump and members of
the majority on this committee
have said they would only vote for a
nominee who would overturn roe versus
wade
as i will lay out in my questioning this
week we shouldn't be having this hearing
with two members of the committee
infected with kovid it's rushed
it constitutes court packing and her
views are too extreme
to qualify her to serve on this court
and of course joe biden
like a good empty suited would-be
presidential figurehead
is repeating this line himself and
adding his own twist to it listen
look the only court packing
going on right now is going on with
republicans attacking the court now
it's not constitutional what they're
doing we should be focused on what's
happening
right now and the fact is that the only
packing going on
is this court is being packed now by the
republicans
after the vote has already begun i'm
going to stay
focused on it so we don't take the eyes
off the ball here
it's unconstitutional what they're doing
oh really how so
where is it written in the constitution
that presidents are only allowed to
nominate justices for the first
three and a half years of their
presidency but then after that it's a
grace period for the other party
and the president has to pretend he
isn't president even though he is
where is that can you please can you
give me chapter and verse here because
joe i i've looked and i haven't found it
but i suppose i suppose we shouldn't
expect coherence um from the same guy
who says that voters don't deserve to
know his own position
on the subject of court packing he was
asked about this and said
explicitly no they don't deserve to know
listen
i've got to ask you about packing the
courts and i know that you said
yesterday you aren't going to answer the
question until after the election
but this is the number one thing that
i've been asked about from viewers uh in
the past couple of days well
you've been asked by the viewers who are
probably republicans who don't want me
continuing to talk about what they're
doing to the court right now
well sir don't the voters deserve to
know no they don't disagree i'm not
going to play his game
he'd love me to talk about and i've i've
already said something on
corporate he loved that to be the
discussion instead of what he's doing
now
they don't deserve to know he says the
voters do not deserve to know
what the president's actual policy
position is
the voters do not deserve to know if the
guy who is running for president
will overturn over a century of
precedent
and reshape the court by force setting
off a court-packing arms race where
every successive president
will add seats until there are 600 seats
on the court with no end to the
expansion in sight
we don't deserve to know that
interesting coming from the guy who
recently tweeted
the american people deserve to know what
donald trump is hiding in his tax
returns
so to be clear here's the deal as biden
would say the deal is
that the american people deserve to know
the personal financial information of
the president
but they don't deserve to know about his
public policy positions
even one as consequential as this so it
looks like the word
deserves has also been redefined
which i suppose had already happened
it's been redefined a long time ago
so to review now the democrats have
advanced
two primary arguments to defend their
view that
amy cody barrett should not have been
nominated and shouldn't be confirmed
one is that it defies the magisterial
dying wish of ruth bader ginsburg that's
one of their arguments
the other is that any time a republican
fills a vacant court seat it is
automatically a court packing
scheme and is also unconstitutional
even though the constitution expressly
gives them the authority to do it
these are their arguments you can decide
for yourself whether
they are persuasive or not let's get to
five headlines
[Music]
you know we're all spending our lives
online probably
much more than we should be but if
you're online you've got to make sure
you're protecting yourself protecting
your online data
here's something you might not know
about synthetic identity fraud it's one
of the fastest growing financial crimes
in the united states it happens when
criminals use a combination of fake and
real information to create an entirely
new identity
they combine real person personally
identifiable information such as such as
your social security number
with a fake name and address to open
bank accounts
they can seek credit they can even
obtain health insurance it's important
to understand how cyber crime and
identity theft are affecting our lives
and they're affecting our lives in many
many ways every day we put our
information at risk on the internet
and you could miss certain identity
threats if you're just looking at your
credit score or checking your bank
accounts those are good things to do but
you're going to miss a lot of stuff if
you do it just like that
that's why you need lifelock lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number
being for sale in the dark web um and
you know the other thing is people
people i i know we've all made mistakes
sometimes we're we're more reckless than
we should be
uh like things people do like uh have
the same password for
all of your different accounts i
understand the
the inclination to do that right because
you have so many accounts and you i know
for me i come up with a password i
forget it two seconds later so i'm
always doing the forgot password thing
and then i
email to you i do that over and over
again with all my accounts but when you
when you have the same password you're
leaving yourself vulnerable to
um to identity theft
and that's again why you need lifelock
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can find out if your
information is on
is on the dark web get your free dark
web scan at lifelock.com
scan pick the plan that's right for you
save up 25 off
with code walsh as well that's a free
scan at lifelock.com
scan and 25 off with promo code walsh
all right number one a trump supporter
was shot and killed at a protest in
denver over the weekend
he apparently sprayed mace at the
shooter um
who responded by killing him you could
see a photo of the
fateful encounter here
mace is is not a lethal weapon so
this would seem to be a disproportionate
response
now the man with the gun is named
matthew doloff
he was arrested for murder at the scene
the interesting thing is that apparently
he was hired as private security by a
local news station that's nbc affiliate
nine news
and here's the other interesting thing
according to city officials doloff was
not licensed as a security guard in the
city
so it would seem that a news channel
hired whether knowingly or not
an unlicensed armed security guard who
then proceeded to
shoot and kill a pro-trump demonstrator
this ought to warrant charges i would
think not just for doloff but
for nine news as well all right number
two keith olbermann
still exists apparently uh it seems we
haven't heard much from him in recent in
recent years
that's at least i hadn't heard anything
from him i assumed that he had returned
to his lair deep in the earth somewhere
but he has re-emerged now he has been uh
maybe summoned
after somebody read a curse from an old
book in an attic somewhere
and now he's back on the scene and he's
about as reasonable
and coherent as
you remember listen trump can be
and must be expunged the hate he has
triggered
the pandora's box he has opened they
will not be so easily destroyed
so let us brace ourselves the task is
twofold
the terrorist trump must be defeated
must be destroyed must be devoured at
the ballot box
and then he and his enablers and his
supporters
and his collaborators and the mike lees
and the william
bars and the sean hannity's and the mike
pence's and the rudy giuliani's and the
kyle rittenhouse's
and the amy coney barretts must be
prosecuted and convicted
and removed from our society while we
try to rebuild it
and to rebuild the world trump has
nearly destroyed
by turning it over to a virus remember
it
even as we dream of a return to reality
and safety and the country
for which our forefathers died that the
fight is not just to win
an election but to win it by enough to
chase
at least for a moment trump and the
maggots
off the stage and then try to clean up
what they left
remember it even though two remember it
means remembering that the fight does
not end
november third but in many ways
will only begin that day yes he says
that amy coney barrett
along with bill bard of course trump and
a number of others
should be prosecuted convicted and
removed from society
first of all when we're in the midst of
you know the media's blaming donald
trump for supposedly
encouraging violence or encouraging
white supremacists which which he's not
doing but how about this you've got
a prominent i guess i guess he's still
prominent you've got a prominent voice
on the left
at least a well-known voice saying that
amy coney barrett
supreme court nominee should be removed
from
society
look i understand that in the feverish
fantasy-fueled minds of leftists
trump is responsible for all manner of
crimes against humanity and so that's
why they're always calling for him to be
arrested
but what crime did amy coney barrett
commit even in their feverish fantasy
filled minds what
what crime are you accusing her of
committing exactly
at least with trump i know what crimes
they're accusing him of committing
like they're accusing him of being a
russian spy okay so i
i understand that it's it's it's
ridiculous but i understand it
what are you even saying that amy coney
barrett did
did she go 12 miles over the speed limit
on the way to dropping your kid off for
soccer practice is that the
is that the crime we're at the point now
where these people they don't even
bother making up a fake crime
they just work themselves into a sweat
and scream that everyone that they don't
like should be in prison
they don't even bother to explain why
that's their argument style
so you say to them uh so here's my view
on this subject
oh yeah well well you should be in
prison
prison go to prison what dude i was just
telling you that
i think batman begins was better than
the dark knight that's that's all i'm
trying to say
um the thing is i i also think
because i know you hear me talking about
this and you're probably thinking well
you're a hypocrite matt because
don't you often say that your political
opponents and many other people should
be locked in prison
well yes i do but i'm a theocratic
fascist so that's my whole thing
right that's part of it if you're
pretending to be opposed to fascism
then this approach doesn't work but
anyway glad to see that uh
olbermann is back always elevating the
national dialogue
doesn't he all right number three julie
barowski is a political commentator more
on the libertarian side of things she
says she was kicked off a flight
because her toddler wouldn't wear a mask
here's the tweet she says we got kicked
off a flight our two and a half year old
wouldn't put on a mask we had practice
beforehand but he wasn't having it
and then she tagged southwest so
apparently she was on southwest he says
southwest staff was apologetic i get
they don't make the rules i hope
airlines ease up the rules because this
really limits families with toddlers
yeah um
well julie here is being uh much nicer
and more polite about it
than i would be if that were me yet
kicked off your flight
two and a half year old won't wear a
mask of course he won't
of course a two and a half year old
won't wear a mask
he here in fact is what i'll say and
there there may be some exceptions for
this but
broadly speaking if you have managed to
scare your two and a half year old to
such an extent
that he will actually keep his mask on
for hours at a time
then i think it's very likely you're a
horrible parent
and person i
i just i can't even conceive i've got a
three-year-old
almost four uh and and he won't keep his
a mask on and we don't i'm not gonna
force him to uh i most of the time when
we're going in somewhere i don't even
give him a mask we just go in and
that's it or i'll hand it to him and
then he'll immediately like put it in
his pocket
fine i did my i you know i tried to
comply with the rules
i did my part um
two and a half year old though is that's
just crazy to even expect it
and so i'm just trying to imagine to get
a two and a half year old to do that i
mean it's possible you have a two and a
half year old with the
extremely sort of obedient personality
and
extremely cooperative maybe there are a
few of those two and a half year olds
out there
but the vast majority of them are not
going to do that
in order to get them to do it you would
the the
psychological manipulation you would
have to employ
to convince them to do it and keep it on
their face
is unthinkable to me
this whole thing is crazy this is
absolutely insane um
and never mind the fact that the the
it has been repeatedly shown that
there's very that there's
probably a very low risk of a someone
who's two and a half
contracting or spreading the virus um
and on top of that remember that
what we're always told right is you wear
the mask
for me right you wear the mask for me
you don't wear it for yourself you wear
it for other people
and so when we are forcing crying
confused
scared toddlers to wear masks we can't
even pretend we're doing it for their
sake
can we
we're doing it for us we're doing it to
protect
us to protect us from them
that's what we're doing it's cowardly
it's disgusting it's disgraceful
shame on uh southwest for that
and yes they have the right to make
whatever rules they want for their
business but that doesn't mean
that if if the rules are insane
um that doesn't mean we can't criticize
it and we can here and we should
number four speaking of insane gal gadot
is going to star in a movie about
cleopatra
and that's not the insane part that part
you know it's fine because we live in
the dumbest possible world this has
provoked backlash from people who are
mad
that cleopatra's ethnicity or or her
ethnic identity
is being appropriated one person leading
the charge
is abdul el-sayed cnn commentator and
public health doctor self-described he
says
so there were no egyptian women to play
um an egyptian queen
yes very offensive very offensive i'm
also scandalized that they couldn't find
anyone who actually was alive in the
year 50 bc
i mean you're telling me that out of all
the 2000 year old people on earth you
couldn't find
one to play this role someone who could
speak authentically to the lived
experience of people who lived 50 years
before christ
of course looked at another way this is
all very stupid very very
very very stupid for many reasons not
the least of which being that cleopatra
wasn't egyptian actually she was greek
second uh are there is so
every time we hear this oh you we
couldn't find an actor or actress of
this
uh ethnicity to play this role well
how do you know there are i mean are
there egyptian actresses who could play
this role effectively
who would actually be best for it maybe
there are maybe there aren't i don't
know
you're just assuming it at the very
least if you're going to do this
put forward a person who you think would
be better for the role an actual person
not an ethnicity or a skin color an
actual person
and then explain why you think they're
better for it
going beyond their ethnicity or skin
color
but all of that is irrelevant because
the third point of course is that the
job of an actor
is to pretend to be what they are not
that is literally the entire job
that is what they are paid to do and it
used to
be that the further uh
an act actor or actress was from
you know the identity of the role the
more impressed we were with the
performance
in other words the more unlike the actor
is from the role
that's that just makes it even more
impressive
think about um uh you know daniel day
lewis in my left foot
playing a paraplegic he's not paraplegic
himself
and these days you could never get away
with that because it would be said well
what about a paraplegic actor
i don't know how many of parabolic
paraplegic actors are there or are you
just saying we can never tell this story
until we have actors of that um
of that identity but you know back then
when it was saying 30
years ago whenever that movie came out
everybody was impressed with the
performance because here's an
able-bodied person
able to portray this role even though
he's he is not
that himself but he was able to
effectively portray it
and uh very impressive it was a great
job
acting precisely because he is so
himself
unlike that role
all right number five finally tucker
carlson last week did a segment on its
show where he discussed ufo sightings
and specifically this
new documentary that was just released
called the phenomenon
here's a clip of the carlson segment
which includes some clips of the
documentary
listen we used to be defensive on this
topic but there's no reason to be there
is now an enormous
amount of evidence including physical
evidence that ufos
whatever they are are real why don't we
know a lot more about this because the
government has hidden that information
from us
outrageously but now some of that
information has come into public view
thanks to a new documentary called the
phenomenon
we learned the feds are hiding more than
we thought they were
all we're saying nobody has to agree
that
why it's there but shouldn't we at least
be spending some money to study
all these phenomena should we study this
stuff
the answer is yes and that's all this
was about
and why the federal government all these
years has covered up
put brake pads on everything stopped it
i think it's very very bad for our
country are you saying that there's
some evidence that still hasn't seen the
light of day i'm saying
most of it hasn't seen the light of day
it's outrageous
and it's not a partisan question by the
way that of course was former senate
majority leader harry reid of nevada
a democrat if there ever was one but
that's not even the biggest claim he
makes according to the film reed
said that ufos have actually and
repeatedly interfered
with our nuclear weapons capabilities so
where these ufos from
some researchers told the filmmakers
that their origins are becoming clearer
dr jacques valet has collected purported
metal debris from ufo cases
dating as far back as 1947
that experts are analyzing in a
state-of-the-art laboratory
he was astonished to find their
composition was unlike
any known metal this material was
manufactured
it's not natural it's not natural to
the materials that we have around us in
the lab
or on the earth yeah physical evidence
of extraterrestrial spaceships visiting
earth not a big deal
it's nothing compared like the fly on
mike pence's forehead and he's right you
know
the most amazing thing about all this is
that so few people seem to care
we've got photographic evidence video
evidence physical evidence
of these things and everyone just sort
of shugs their shoulders
and moves on now i watched the
documentary myself after seeing the
carlson segment
and uh as one of the weirdos who myself
i'm one of the weird people where i've
watched a bunch of ufo documentaries
in my day i can say that this one this
one is by far and away
the most credible and impressive of any
that i've ever seen
um even the narrator who you heard there
he's
i don't know what his name is but i i
recognize that voice i watch a lot of
documentaries in general
uh and he you know this is a guy who
does like ken burns
films and pbs documentaries a mainstream
documentary narrator and the film
includes as you saw
former prominent very prominent
government officials politicians
former military officials scientists
these are credible
people for the most part i mean harry
reid i don't know if i'd call him
credible in fact i wouldn't
but even there when it comes to
ideological things i don't think he's
credible but
that he's putting his name next to this
also they've got supposed eyewitnesses
uh lots of photographic and video
evidence like i mentioned all the
documentary
the thing is one objection you often
hear to the ufo claims is that well
if ufos were real and aliens were
were actually visiting we should have
very good evidence of it by now
why is it that like with bigfoot somehow
nobody's ever come forward with
really remarkable physical evidence or
video evidence of this
why is it that even in modern times
everybody who records one
one of these phenomena uh you know
manages to get video of it
seems to be recording it with their
grandmother's toaster oven
why isn't it that everyone's carrying
around these really advanced
videos uh um
you know cameras are in their pockets
why why hasn't it ever been captured
well the thing is that's true of bigfoot
yeah that's very good argument against
bigfoot a lot of good arguments against
it but one of them is just
we've never had there's never been
anything close to actual compelling
evidence of that
as far as ufos though actually there has
been
a lot of really good evidence photos
videos physical evidence
it just seems that nobody believes it
even the good evidence nobody believes
and so you start to think what kind of
evidence would the average person
actually need to see in order to
entertain the idea that maybe this
really is
extraterrestrial in origin probably
short of being personally visited by
alien beings
the average person won't be convinced by
the way
um and not to say that i'm convinced as
in i'm
i'm 100 on board that i'm sure that
these are aliens i'm just saying that
this a lot of this stuff is interesting
and the photographic evidence goes back
decades there there have been very
interesting photos of
flying saucers from the 50s that have
been investigated by various government
government commissions and so forth and
have been labeled unexplained as in
they aren't obviously manipulated or
staged none of the obvious explanations
hold
so we're left with what is it
so there's something going on here i i
think we could say at a minimum with
certainty
that we have proof of the existence of
aircraft that far exceeds
the known technological ability of
modern
man and we say far exceeds we mean stuff
that is like hundreds of years or more
beyond
our known capabilities it's easy to
speculate of course that some
government somewhere has this technology
and is testing it out but the problem is
that first of all
these sightings go back to the 40s and
50s
if if a world government somewhere
had access to this technology 70 years
ago
you'd think they would have used it by
now in a very noticeable
significant way is it believable that
some other world power
is that far ahead of us and yet hasn't
used
that power in any noticeable way i don't
know
of course when you compare that
explanation which seems implausible
with the idea that some intelligent
civilization has visited
which both are implausible which is more
implausible
and you could make a good argument that
the alien civilization is more
impossible but still
there's there's definitely something
going on here and we get to the point
where you have government officials
on the record saying i don't know this
this is weird
that that should make us take notice i
think
all right um of course you always have
to guard against wishful thinking with
these sorts of things because
i would love for it to actually be
aliens just because that would be cool
and even if they're if they're coming
here to invade the earth and kill us
all all right okay that's
we had a good run i'm okay with that too
so uh yeah
there there's a silver lining to that as
well so you have to guard against the
wishful thinking when it comes to these
kinds of things
we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation just a second but before we
do
i want to tell you about um our good
friends over at ready wise we've been
telling you for a long time about wise
foods well now they
are ready wise that's the new name and
you know you've got to be prepared
speaking of things happening in the
future you've got to be prepared for
whatever happens in the future even if
it's an alien invasion
if but even but but it could be
something a little bit less interesting
than that
we've discovered that in in recent times
as well you never know what's going to
happen and you've got to be prepared
now is a is a is a better time than any
to be prepared
with long-term nutritional food options
ready wise has many options like
emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition they also
have adventure meals for hiking camping
other
outdoor activities so this is stuff that
you could use even
if there's not some sort of emergency
situation just in your everyday life
due to increased demand supplies are
limited some items may be currently out
of stock what that just means is
you've got to go right now and get your
get your order in ready wise uses the
finest ingredients and latest food
preparation technology to ensure optimal
taste and freshness
every recipe is crafted by a team of
chefs to provide a nutritional meal
during critical times and it also tastes
good on top of that each meal is a
combination of both dehydrated and
freeze-dried ingredients
meals are packed into durable
long-lasting pouches designed to keep
food fresh for up to 25 years
you've just you've got to take
responsibility and be prepared in times
like these
and this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com when entering
walsh at checkout or by calling
855-475-3089
ready wise is a 99 90 day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative
to get yourself and your family prepared
today that's ready wise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get free
shipping today
and one other thing to mention to you um
something going on
here at the daily wire it's baseball
season and the old glory
daily wire baseball bat is back that's
our limited edition handcrafted custom
painted baseball bat emblazoned
with the daily wire logo when we first
put this pad out a numbered
a numbered edition a few months ago it
sold out in 48 hours
that's how quickly it went away and that
was when it was available to all
to all access members only now anybody
can purchase it
but inventory is still limited so we had
it available just to all access members
48 hours it was gone now it's for
everybody
so what you gotta do is act fast text
the word
baseball to eight three four zero
zero that's baseball to eight three four
zero zero
to purchase your bat today all right
let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation as it
is columbus day i will
as is my custom and has been for years
now deliver my defense
of the great man christopher columbus as
we know columbus day
has become primarily an opportunity for
historically illiterate preening
dimwits to spend their time screeching
about a fictional version of history
where europeans were the first to
introduce rape pillage and slavery to
the universally peaceful
and noble inhabitants of the new world
of course in reality it'd be quite
impossible for the spanish to introduce
rape pillage and slavery
uh to this part of the world where rape
pillar pillage and slavery
have been utterly commonplace for
centuries as it had been commonplace
everywhere on the globe but don't tell
that to the dimwit dimwits
the dimwits who you'll notice say they
hate columbus and
you know everything he stood for and
represents yet will still take the day
off if it's offered to them they don't
hate them that much
and speaking of dimwits again the dimwit
capital
dimwitia as we might call it portland
saw another riot last night this time
under the name of indigenous people day
of rage
and it was a chance for indigenous
people or those who claim to be
or the allies of such or just people who
feel like you know tearing stuff down
to go around destroying things anything
at random
because they're enraged they have rage
you see they have rage over events that
occurred over 500 years ago
and because of this rage they uh they
have as you can see here this this photo
toppled uh in an abraham lincoln statue
and other statues
they're mad about stuff that happened
500 years ago so they tore down the
statue of a man who lived
150 years ago makes sense actually no it
doesn't
and aside from the general general
historical literacy of the anti-columbus
faction
it must also be said that if you're
experiencing actual rage over things
that happened
half a millennium ago you are mentally
ill
it's not normal or healthy to be sitting
around in the year 2020
stewing over stuff that happened in the
year 1506
but obviously i'm being intentionally
naive the people rioting they're not
enraged about anything
they're just bored and numb and
destroying stuff because they can
and it's fun now getting back to the
broader war against our national heroes
one that is largely led not by
indigenous people but by white liberals
and you'll notice something about these
self-hating white guilt-ridden folks
they would never suggest that the
nightmarish brutality of many native
american tribes outweighs whatever they
accomplished
even the propensity for cannibalism
among some tribes must be understood in
context we're told
yet somehow the sins of some european
settlers automatically negates
everything that european explorers
achieved and discovered and besides of
course the modern critic will note
columbus didn't even mean to discover
america and he never he never set foot
in north america
and the vikings got here first what an
idiot [ __ ]
yes those are all nice tidbits of
information you acquired from facebook
memes
but they're irrelevant of course
columbus didn't mean to discover america
nobody knew that america existed
how does that undermine the significance
of the discovery if some future team of
intrepid astronauts accidentally
discover a life-bearing moon on jupiter
on their way to exploring pluto should
we dismiss their groundbreaking history
shaping discovery on the basis that they
originally intended to make a different
groundbreaking history shaving discovery
as for the vikings again
how is columbus's incredible feat
diminished
by leif erikson's exploits in a
relatively small sliver of the north
atlantic 500 years prior
you may as well say that it would be
unimpressive for me to cure cancer
because jonas salk already cured polio
we should also remember and it seems
that modern people really have forgotten
this fact
that columbus did not have the benefit
of satellite navigation
he made his way by dead reckoning
through uncharted waters
most of us cannot even conceive of what
that would be like
to go to go sailing over an ocean ocean
you have no idea how big it is or where
it leads
over the course of his voyages he
discovered many caribbean islands
explored the coasts of south and central
america
he didn't make it to north america but
he made it possible for future settlers
to soon find it that's quite an
achievement i would say
or must he be blamed for only
discovering half of the western
hemisphere while recklessly neglecting
to discover the other half
that guy only discovered half of a
hemisphere what a dope
that seems a rather stringent standard
especially coming from people who can't
locate their local supermarket without
gps assistance and what about the
natives that columbus encountered yes
many of them were peaceful
and we all agree that mistreatment of
peaceful people is wrong
anywhere it happens by the same token we
should bear in mind that the roast
the sort of russoian vision of the
universally noble savage
occupying the new world was incorrect
and ridiculous
columbus was for example in the
neighborhood of the caribs of violent
people
who would capture and consume other
human beings
columbus heard stories about these uh
this tribe and and uh on his first
voyage
bumped into them on a second columbus
was close to aztec territory as well
he never met them that civil
civilizational clash would be saved for
later but
it's worth noting that the aztec empire
was not exactly a picture of peace and
serenity
tens of thousands of people were
captured and killed as human sacrifices
every year in macabre in macabre
religious ceremonies
an offering was laid on a stone slab at
the top of a temple
his beating heart was ripped out of his
chest his arms and legs were often
hacked off and consumed by the priests
and his limbless carcass was rolled down
the steps
this process was repeated dozens or even
hundreds of times
in a single night and and thousands of
times over the course of a year
now for a long time historians and
archaeologists assured us that the
spanish
fabricated or exaggerated these stories
of aztec barbarism
uh they say the same about the stories
of uh of carib barbarism
but then they discovered the skull racks
buried in mexico city
columbus never governed with the
savagery of an aztec king or a carib
chieftain
but he did take slaves that's true he
was a man of his time in that way
although the spanish would eventually
outlaw slavery and beat almost every
other culture in the world by hundreds
of years in doing so
they cannot be absolved of their role in
that ubiquitous evil
neither can they be uniquely blamed for
it either that's the point
we can wag our fingers about it but we
cannot wag our fingers selectively
if we call the spanish genocidal we must
say the same about indigenous people who
participated in the same kinds of crimes
if we convict the europeans of stealing
land
we must convict the natives for the same
crime we must convict
all of history in fact and all people
because before the globe was settled and
we could all live comfortably in
a country where the greatest threat to
our survival for most of us
is that the doordash guy will take more
than 25 minutes to deliver our
take out sushi before all of that every
inch of inhabited space was fought over
and
blood soaked the ground and a man
could only claim what he was willing and
able to kill
to keep you did not own anything that
you could not defend
i am not saying the world should have
been that way
i'm saying that my ideas of what should
have been are irrelevant
i'm telling you what was and it was that
way
everywhere for all people for thousands
of years
the knife of historical moralizing then
only cuts whoever tries to wield it
so i suggest that we mature a little bit
and learn to view history in its context
seen through that lens columbus appears
before us as a deeply flawed but
incredibly brave and ingenious man
who is responsible for one of the great
achievements in the history of mankind
perhaps you could have done better but
probably not
you probably wouldn't have even tried
and that's why columbus gets his own
holiday and you don't
he earned it you might complain about
him
but i take note of the fact that you
still remain in in this country
living off the fat of its land and
enjoying fruit from trees planted by
people
greater and more significant than
yourself so go ahead and scoff at those
men
as you feast on the bounty they provided
you
but you know pardon me while i dismiss
your criticism
and offer a little toast to christopher
columbus
and to everybody else who has a balanced
view of history
to the people who don't i say
you're canceled columbus is not you are
uh and we'll leave it there happy
columbus day everybody
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
the moderator of the next presidential
debate gets caught
as a partisan hack democrats try to
redefine court packing
and the who comes out against lockdowns
check it out
on the michael knowles show
[Music]